and i've got a quote from tyson fury
here i read that he tweeted
at you
i would eat him up and spit him out
seven times a day as a tyson fury set up
for you do you think that uh you'd have
tyson in a in the ring
i think i can take everybody
[Music]
can you tell me where were you born and
what was your childhood like
i was born in cameroon
in a small village named bati in my
village there was nothing there i mean
there's a small village we didn't even
have a light
we didn't have anything i grew up in the
small
house and sometimes we are sleeping if
it's raining it's just gonna leaked
inside the houses because the zing was
all
messed up you know so we grew up in that
condition so how come like you were
fighting every day to have what to eat
so how come do you gonna think about gym
or fighting my older brother and i or
he's older than me
he's two years older than me so we had
to find something to provide to work so
we went to the sandman because our we
have a uncle which is
a
who walked in the sign mine so we were
going with him
to work
and at first it was very hard to show
osan at age nine
i was just so little but the
lucky us we were strong
when you were in working in the sand
mine did you actually always think i
want to be a fighter
uh not like a fighter but one thing for
sure i knew i didn't belong there
but uh to say it out loud was like
insulting other people that was there
for somehow i always have a higher
expectation of myself i always view
myself like
you know
like somebody who can get something done
and um
[Music]
or at least somebody who can try even if
he didn't if he doesn't get it done at
least he tried i left school at 17
still like doing
small jobs at town uh for five years
until i was 22 i'm like okay i'm done
surviving i'd really have to live my
life now doesn't matter what is the
outcome if it doesn't work it doesn't
work at least
i'm
living my dream so that's how i let i
let everything in the village and when
in the
in the city in dwara i first went in
yonder
he was really hot then i went into allah
find a gym
start training
that's quite late to start training
isn't it that's what that's what
everybody says i'm like oh it's late or
you never take care of yourself you
always sick you don't go to the hospital
oh forget about it
oh man
i heard everything about it so
but i was so stubborn i love it so much
that i'm like i finally had the
opportunity to do it i've been waiting
this for like my entire life i mean i
always knew that uh even though i love
this sport so much even though i love
camber sport so much cameron is not a
way for me to like
um
like like shine you know so i know he
has to be somewhere else but where and
how to go
you know i can't afford a visa i can
afford anything i can't even afford a
plane ticket
um
so that was the biggest the hardest part
but what i do realize
was that boxing was more
uh
was bigger in europe i mean i would have
like always liked america over uh
preferably but
europe was the only the continent that
you can go from africa to europe
the journey you went through is
unbelievable
you started from cameroon then went into
the neighborhood
cameron nigeria
niger
algeria morocco
like
25 people in the back of a small pickup
truck
and everybody will be holding like
something like this and they are going
like
like
80 miles per hour
in the uh desert
and you everybody has to hold on into
something because
if otherwise you will fall and if you
fall
they are not stopping
so you end up in morocco and then from
morocco you're trying to get into europe
yeah yeah
and you had multiple attempts multiple
attempts trying to cross the
mediterranean yeah
even even multiple attempts also trying
to
jump to the fence
in a million
what would they do to you think when
they cut when they caught you
so usually in the fans uh when they
caught you in the fence you get beat up
really bit up basically if you're a big
guy because there they just know that
for them they assume that the biggest
the biggest guy is the leader in the
ocean when they caught you there because
yes in the middle of the ocean with your
little like
flightable boat you can do do anything
you know
so when they cut you they will bring you
uh
in a j in jail
for a couple days kind of like send you
down down until like usda which is like
way south and then from usda they will
bring you
uh
not in the middle of the desert but like
um
somewhere in the beginning a little a
little bit far so for you to go back
what was the closest you came and then
you were stopped that was in december
2012 and then uh
that was the first time that i was a uh
kind of like a captain
those kids they went like uh convinced
their brother to buy a boat and bring it
and i was a captain because i've been
there so many times
but uh we paddled about like three hours
so we were sure that we made it
that we're gonna get rescue rescued by
a red cross or something
and uh there wasn't a court uh coast
guard anymore
there was this ship
for moroccan army they were going from
somewhere i don't know big ship
though i don't know where they were
coming from and where we're going to
but and they were behind us they passed
us
and then like
go go ahead
and then turn and come in front of us
so with that big ship in front of you
like this
you don't know if you don't even know
where you were going you don't know
where is the south or where is the north
and uh they called the uh they called
the
coast guard to come get us
and since i think that was my sixth my
my fifth time my sixth time
and since that day i was so
upset that um i was like okay
whenever i touched this water i'm not
coming back
i tried six times i fell six times
then the seventh time i succeeded
like even when you made it
yes you made it you're in the you know
in a
spin territory
but still
because
when you get there when the racecross
rescue they give you to the uh
police to the border security you know
to control and obviously you have no
papers people so they'll kind of like
keep
put you in jail
and that that's like a torture you know
they kind of like play with your mind
have you ever seen those movie and that
they caught some somebody and want to
interrogate him and put him in the room
like this put all like white light on
him for like three days
they didn't do that but that's how you
feel you feel that pressure like okay
i'm done guys if you want to send me
back send me back now but leave me alone
set me free i can't do this anymore
and we were there for like two months
yeah
so you were in europe
but kind of like can you at least let me
go
i mean i rather you bring me back in
morocco i just
you know and then once you were released
from the spanish jail
you did you then you went you eventually
made your way to paris
the next day i found it
i just walk around to look at the gym
and then i met a guy
dj camo and in the gym
and i think the guy that guy is there is
the most reason why
i stay in paris the way that he treated
me and how he kind of like
look
after me
i think he makes me feel a little
comfortable like relaxing
and then that's how i stay in paris
so now after 14 months of hardship
you are about to start doing the thing
that you wanted to do yeah which was
train and fight
did that feel you with so much
excitement
still now still now i think
that's arguably the best moment of my
life
you know i was so happy so excited full
of
enthusiasm
and
people was telling me people was
talking to me and
knowing that i'm
i'm sleeping in the street
you know and there will be like
something is not right here this guy is
homeless but he seems like
very excited like in my
we might be missing something here you
know my own problem uh was has always
been to have an opportunity to be in a
land of important opportunity because
the other moment that must be the
happiest moment of your life must be
when you were to become the heavyweight
champion
by the time i become i became a
heavyweight champion of the war i think
i've been through so many quitting a lot
of good things
things have have happened in my life and
so he was a process it's not like i just
wake up one day and become a world
champion you know
even that moment getting in paris was a
part of becoming a heavyweight champion
but this one was a unique and first
opportunity ever like i feel i felt free
for the first time in my life i felt
like i have my own chance
i'm gonna ask some questions now just
about yourself and like and your future
because you're heavyweight champion of
the world
huge title but you also you're you have
the world record for the hardest ever
recorded punch that's what is it
i've got to hear that it says
it's like getting hit by a ford escort
going at full speed is what the the cmo
the power i never feel it so i don't
know
i don't i want it to stay like this i
don't want to feel it
you've had your fights outside the ring
too and you fought with the ufc slightly
over
pay disputes and stuff like that now how
do you feel about the jake paul's
campaign to uh get fighters paid more
i mean uh i have heard a lot of things
about
what he's he said or a lot of comment
about him but personally
i think everything that he say makes
sense
personally i think
[Music]
because ufc is a big industry today and
those industry you have to remember that
his build on fire is based on fighter
without fighter
the industry is nothing so personally i
will even go further and say
when
we need fire need a
rep advocate somebody will advocate for
them in the ball meeting
you know somebody will defend their
right
because yes
we are in the uh how they call this
menopause somebody make the rules and
decide oh that's the rule or you break
the rules which room oh i just
make it up you can fight you can argue
that you can fight it
at some point we need some kind of like
some management about that and then i
want to talk about potential fights in
the future
obviously where we're filming this today
uh on the it's just before the um tyson
fury dylan white fight there has been
rumors that one day there might be a
super fight between you and and tyson
i think it's more than rumors i want it
for sure and i know it doesn't want it
so that's why eventually will happen in
the future when i don't know
but i know it's going to happen do you
fancy him to beat dylan white tonight
yeah if we want to keep this fight going
if we want to see this fight next year
yes i want him uh he better win tonight
you know
he said he sent me the same message he
said the same thing to me last time
so i'm returning him
the same thing
and i've got a quote from tyson fury
here i read that he tweeted
at you
i would eat him up and spit him out
seven times a day as a tyson fury said
about you do you think that uh you'd
have tyson in a in the ring
i think i can take everybody
you know like
even the fact that i'm here like
we are discussing about thing like
something will make sense you know it's
just a proof that i can't make it
he's a great boxer
one of the best ever
do it you know
personally i think he's a he's a show
guy he's a good show guy he like have
fun
he's
cool
and what i love about him he's a free
man you know he speak free
he live free
you know he's not
cage
and i like that attitude ten years ago
i wasn't in the picture
not even in the corner like a dot you
know
so i have my own chance obviously it's
not my comfort zone it's not
i know that he's
expert in that
in that in that discipline but
man
don't never count me out but your family
and your village they must be so pride
of what you've achieved
yeah they were pride proud at some time
at some point um you know basically at
the beginning but over uh with time
he doesn't he became
not for my family anymore he became for
the entire country
you know
my family they can they cannot uh
claim me they cannot say oh it's our
friends that will get beat up is
cameronian francis
heavyweight champion we have seen a lot
of heavyweight champion
and after me there will be a lot of
heavyweight champion you know
and i will just be one of them one of
hundreds or
thousands of them you know
i would not choose to do any of that
thing things at all to be in that to go
to that route but i think that's what
defined me from my childhood to all the
way that i get to get there i when i
think about it i think that's what make
it even that's the beautiful part of it
my story
my life that's my
and my only that belongs to me
you can never really be true friends
after something like that i just don't
think it can ever ever happen maybe if
you
fought and it was a draw maybe you could
still be friends but
the idea of being friends with someone
that
has a beating you it's a hard thing for
your head to compute